Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, House of the Dragon Season
2 has a first look at Aemond Targaryen
and a bunch of other scenes at major
locations like the Returning to the Wall.
There are a couple of huge Dragon
battle scenes, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes Right now
they're one of the few shows
that were able to continue shooting
throughout the strike.
That's happening
because most of the actors
aren't actually part of the guild
that's doing all the striking,
with a few exceptions,
they have enough foreign actors and people
working on the show in major roles
that they didn't have to start.
That's why are new scenes from season two
and why
they'll still hit their original release
window of next summer in 2024.
But the first big scenes are of Aemond
Targaryen in ser weird footsteps layers
strong himself at the red
keep in two different scenes,
but they're both at the red.
Keep The scene of almond is of him
watching as he has to the city
watch soldiers execute
two different people in the courtyard
now with green highlights on their armor
because the Green's had everyone's colors
changed to match green for gold symbols
for Aegon after the ending of season one.
this is likely later in the season
and he's executing to traitors to
the Greens are two important laws
that won't switch sides for the blacks
to the Greens,
or the just two laws that won't follow
orders given to them by the Greens, Almond
and everyone else There's also a theory
that this is happening a little bit later
in the season.
Like the second half of the season
in Prince Ahmed might have temporarily
already become Prince region, while Aegon
is recuperating from his wounds
suffered at Rooks Rest,
which is supposed to be episode four.
so this might be happening during episode
five.
The battle at Rooks
Rest is going to be one of the big
mid-season WTF battles that they're doing.
This is a huge battle orchestrated
by the Greens against the blacks.
Christine Kohl,
who had just become the hand of the king,
used his elevated position in power
within the Green Council
to try and take rooks rest
The whole idea that they were trying
to be way more aggressive in their tactics
against Bernier inside Rooks
rest is right here, right along the bay
next to Dragonstone.
So this strategic position
was important for them
and they wanted to use it as a trap
against the blacks.
they had just won a bloodless battle
at the sack of dusk and Dale nearby
with Lord Crosbie and Lord
Stoke worth bending the need to Aegon
in exchange for their lives.
so that easy victory emboldened
the Greens to try and push to rooks rest
so Christine called tried to set a trap
for Raniere inside at Rooks rest
using 3000 of their men in two dragons
they gar almond in Sunfire
ridden by Aegon
The Lord Mosby,
the ruler of House Staunton
that Rooks rest here
sent help for Rhaenyra.
Only Rhaenys and her dragon Malays
were able to come help defend
against the Greens
in both of their dragons
end even though it was just
Rhaenys herself against egg on an army,
the idea is that she's
meant to be a vastly superior on Dragon
back as a fighter against both of them.
They kind of tease this
at the end of season one.
Like she could have taken out Aegon
in all of the greens in one fell swoop
if she had wanted to.
The Queen
who didn't say Burn them all this time.
She definitely tries to burn them all.
in on top of this,
a dragon is like a nuclear weapon.
It can take out an entire ground
army by itself.
So on her own,
Rhaenys was able to take out
almost a third of their ground forces
wounded Aegon in Sun Fire so badly
that Aegon was bedridden
for almost a year,
with Amond having to take over his region
temporarily Aegon
never fully recovered Burns covered
half of his body for the rest of his life.
He had to spend most day hocked up on milk
of the poppy just to deal with the pain.
And he wound up being a little bit
like the serious like his quality of life
turned into that of the series
they'll probably see some parallels
for this later in season two and beyond.
he became kind of like a shell of himself,
like he lost the use of his legs
and kind of wished that he had died.
that's how badly he was wounded at Rooks
Rest it's also meant to pay off one
of Helena's Dragon Dragons from season one
where she mentioned him having no legs.
She was talking about Aegon.
I already did a video for the
scenes on the aftermath of the battle,
which they filmed earlier this year.
Like the aftermath of Rooks Rest,
they were filming scenes of Aegon's forces
carting in Meleys
head with a huge procession
routes was ultimately a victory
for the Greens.
They did kill Rhaenys and Meleys
and take the Keep.
But it was meant to be a Pyrrhic victory,
which they foreshadowed in season one.
The idea that the dance of the Dragons
aegon's forces versus Rangers.
Ultimately there will be a winner
like somebody actually
does have to be declared winner.
but this winds up happening
through the multiple battles
that happened through season two,
season three, season four as they go on
regardless of who wins each battle,
both sides ultimately
wind up losing that was what Rhaenyra
was quote, at the beginning of season one.
Opening the entire show was all about
the only thing they can take down
the House of
the Dragon is the house of the dragon
itself, the Scene of sir.
Weird Footsteps.
Larry's strong is of him
shouting down the steps and it looks like
he's fully entered the role
of Master of Whispers for the Greens.
That was part of his arc at the end
of House of the Dragon season one.
Like they gave him the lordship of hair
and whole, like he basically became
the Lord of his house because he killed
his father and his brother.
But also on the side.
He officially become Aegon,
the second master of whispers.
The next big scene is of them
filming up at the wall
for everybody, wondering
when we're going to see the wall.
A reference House Stark Winterfell
the white walkers again
it seems like this will be a little bit
earlier in the season.
It's supposed to be when Cregan Stark,
Lord of Winterfell at that time
takes Prince Jacaerys
north of the wall
when he's visiting on the orders
of his mother Rhaenyra to try and win.
How Starks allegiance to the blacks.
to kind of fuzzy on how long the timeline
moves along each episode and each season.
They did this on Game of Thrones too.
Well, people
making jokes about the fast travel system.
but you, Chris, winds up
spending a good amount of time up
at Winterfell trying to win his allegiance
the big difference at this point
in the timeline though,
is that their relationship
between how stark and the targaryens
is much better than it was
during the events of the main show
and Game of Thrones when things picked up.
that was meant to start
in the aftermath of Robert's
rebellion, which had started
because Rhaegar Targaryen
and Jon Snow's mother, Liana Stark,
eloped to the Tower of Joy.
when they disappeared.
Leona's father, Nasdaq's father as well.
Rick and Stark.
Lord of Winterfell at the time,
went to King's Landing with Ned's older
brother, Brandon, to demand
that heir is the second the Mad King
do something about it
and return her to him.
Remember at the time, because they eloped,
Everybody thought that Ragnar had kidnaped
Lyanna.
Not that she went willingly with him.
the mad king, who had gone very mad later
in his life at this point,
had both Rick in and Ned's older
brother, Brandon Stark, killed,
which was basically the tipping point
where Robert's rebellion actually began.
So when season one begins, old wounds
and all that, lots of bitter energy
against the Targaryen still around.
but none of that had happened
at this point during House of the Dragon.
And it's even rumored that Shakira's
fell in love with Kerrigan's
bastard half sister,
Sarah Snow, while he was at Winterfell.
the pact that they formed when he swears
allegiance to Rhaenyra is also called
the Pact of Ice and Fire,
another reference
to a song of Ice and Fire,
which inside the universe of the show
they're now calling egg on the conkers
prophecy about the long night, His Dragon
Dream about the long night.
it's also what George R.R.
Martin used is the name of his saga.
Four main novels in the series like
it's a big me Leonardo DiCaprio moment.
Like, oh, he said the name of the thing
inside the thing
then we'll get to the main events of House
of the Dragon.
Season one in the Dance of the Dragons.
A lot of what's happening in the Stark
family is similar
to what happens in the Targaryen family
with Rhaenyra in the Green's So
Regan
Stark is the current Lord of Winterfell.
He bends the knee to Rhaenyra
during this period, but in that giant time
jump between episode five in episode six,
it's like a ten year time jump.
Basically the exact same thing
happens within House Stark There's
this whole battle of the succession
and this is where you get to Cregan Stark,
like the new main character inside House
Stark in Winterfell during season two.
He's meant to be about the same age
as Jazeera's as Rhaenyra said.
Oh, you'll get along just fine.
This will be great.
They'll totally support us.
that's why she decided to send him
instead of sending Lou.
Sarah's. in the books.
Cregan is just a little bit older
than just Sarah's In
what happened during all those time jumps
between episode five and episode six?
Is that Rick and Stark, the older
Lord of Winterfell, passed away
before the events of Episode six
in when that happened
Cregan was way too young to be a lord.
So his uncle named Bernard Stark,
Regan's brother became regent
until Cregan came of age.
but right towards the end of the time
jump In episode six, Cregan comes of age
and his uncle Bernard refused to hand over
control of Winterfell in the north.
So the Starks had their own minor
little dance of the Dragons type of event
over the battle in succession.
it wasn't nearly as big or crazy
as the actual dance of the Dragons itself,
And when we get to
the events of episode ten,
when they're actually talking
about going to Winterfell
to form a bargain
with them to support the blacks.
Cregan Stark
has already defeated his uncle,
thrown him in prison
and taken control of Winterfell.
What happened to Cregan in between
the events of Episode six and Episode
ten, though, is that after
he defeats his uncle,
he winds up marrying his childhood
sweetheart named Alison Norrie.
They had a son who he named Rick
in after his father,
but his wife died soon after because of
the childbirth, because of complications.
Much like Raniere, his mother.
the other new scene is in the West
or lands near the Golden tooth
controlled by the Lannisters.
That's why it looks like Jason
Lannister is leading the Lannister army
to meet what looks like house
leopard who controls the golden tooth.
They're also sworn to the greens as well.
the reason why the Golden Tooth
is so important in the Dance of Dragons
is because it's a huge strategic position
in the Green's supply chain across
that part of the kingdom.
they kind of got into this at the end
of House of the Dragon season one.
Damian was talking about
all the strategic positions
in the kingdom
that they wanted to control.
The Golden Tooth
just happens to be one of them.
if you spotted any other Easter
eggs in the new scenes in footage,
post them in the comments below.
They'll be filming episodes for a while,
so we'll get more footage pretty soon
and probably a big teaser later this year.
typically during the original show,
they wait until January to start releasing
the full trailers, but that usually
premiered earlier in the year.
So because they're premiering this
in the summer, next year,
that means they probably won't release
the first really big trailer
until like April or May.
they'll be a bunch of smaller teasers
before that, though.
So it's not like we're going to go bone
dry until April or May next year.
George R.R.
Martin also confirmed
that they're probably going to do up
to about four seasons
before they wrap up
the dance of the Dragons
and move to the next major
event in a different part of the timeline
with a totally different cast.
But it'll still be called
House of the Dragon,
they haven't confirmed
what that's going to be
or if they're going to go earlier
in the timeline and do Aegon's conquest.
And everybody wants to see Aegon
the Conqueror at some point
or if they're going to go later
in the timeline to do the Blackfire
rebellions, we'll find out about that
probably in the final season of the show.
they do have the Night of the Seven
Kingdoms
series about the tales of Duncan Egg,
but that's meant to be
a totally separate thing.
They're going to be doing those episodes
concurrently with the last couple
of seasons of House of the Dragon,
but because of the delays,
we probably won't see that premiere
until at least 2026.
I've already done a much bigger video
for that night of the Seven Kingdoms
trailer that they released early
this year.
Click here to learn all about that in.
Click here
for all my other House, the Dragon Season
2 teaser videos and first Looks.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!